[Musique]
arrivée dans un nouveau pays une
nouvelle ville comporte son lot de
difficultés pour de nouveaux arrivants
il ya tout une adaptation à la vie
québécoise est l'un des aspects que l'on
soupçonne le moins et l'alimentation
quand on est arrivé ici je pensais que
la prime chose que je dois faire c'est
apprendre le passé et il l'a universités
m'a été beaucoup pour l'international la
société comme os que où l université où
est le premier temps plein toute chose
comme ça mais jamais imaginé que la
nourriture est morte j'ai aussi voulu ma
taille et culturellement à
l'alimentation canadienne et sata passer
par les fast food pour moi et ça a eu un
impact sur ma fille et ma santé
évidemment et a été démontré au canada
que les immigrants arrivés ici en
relativement bonne santé
après quelques années passées sur le
territoire canadien
on avait une détérioration des codes
l'état de santé de ces derniers est donc
cette détérioration elle était en
rapport avec une modification de leurs
habitudes de vie à savoir leur
alimentation l'activité physique
merci beaucoup d'être venu pour
l'atelier d'aujourd'hui bénédicte à la
mène 12 étudie l'impact de
l'alimentation sur les maladies
métaboliques et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
vraiment comment est ce que la
transition alimentaire en arrivant ici
impact la santé métabolique désirant
chips coca et 7
j'ai pris 20 kilos en quelques années
donc c'est il ya eu un impact grand
c'est vrai que j'essaie d'économiser sur
l'argent mais finalement sur la santé
gpi j'ai pas eu de problèmes de santé en
tant que tel mais les facteurs de risque
sont montés
il ya des aliments de chez eux qui vont
pas retrouver ici mais des aliments
locaux qui ne connaissent pas donc ça
déjà c'est un premier vecteur là ils
savent pas comment cuisiner les aliments
locaux qui en général il y mettre de
côté fait déjà la une modification de
l'alimentation et en plus les aliments
de chez eux qu'ils peuvent retrouver ici
les très souvent c'est quand même
relativement dispendieux donc ils
peuvent pas se permettre de préparer des
plats de chez eux tous les jours
bienvenue tout le monde je crois qu'on
doit vraiment de tous les coins du globe
là avec ça fait vraiment plaisir
bénédicte a donc eu l'idée de développer
des ateliers de cuisine en priorisant
les aliments locaux mais avec des
recettes et des épices venues d'ailleurs
vous aurez quand même sur la table
quelques ingrédients un peu propres
quand même à la cuisine africaine de la
recette même vous allez voir que c'est
un mix vraiment entre aliments locales
et une recette africaine
dans les cuisines de l'inaf aujourd'hui
on découvre la courge spaghetti façon
poulet yassa un plat typiquement
sénégalais vous voyez la partie avec les
grains tout ça on veut vraiment
l'enlever donc vous allez bien comme il
faut et vous l'enlever maintenant un peu
d'épicés du piment et du piment doux et
du piment fort et cette immense 7 qui
est quand même assez épicé départ ou do
for quoi ces formules ou qu'ils ont des
épices qui peuvent venir de la cuisine
africaine ou de la cuisine d'amérique
latine parce que je disais que c'était
plus facile d'assimiler l'aliment si on
utilisait des petits ingrédients qu'on a
l'habitude d'utiliser dans la cuisine de
chez lui quand elle va être cuite
si vous prenez une pochette vous la
gratter il ya des petits filaments qui
vont se défaire et c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle la courge spaghetti le fait de
mettre la cause au four moi c'est un peu
original ça m'intrigue pas les chantres
de découvrir et j'ai hâte de voir à quoi
ça va ressembler en effet de pouvoir
conte mouvoir la consommation locale les
mets locaux
donc c'est ce qui m'a vraiment intéressé
dans un atelier en achetant local permet
aussi de pouvoir rémunérer rémunéré à
juste titre les producteurs encourager
l'économie locale et aussi contribuer à
la réduction de la pollution mais ni si
ça permet aussi de d'élargir notre champ
de vision
vous savez j'avais déjà mangé constituer
la gorge mais je n'avais jamais vu ça de
ma façon dont ça va être aujourd'hui
j'avais acheté de com de la junte fait
au four déjà préparé je regarde je vois
des légumes à l'inter j'ai dit c'est
quoi ça puis j'ai demandé à une amie
mais 10 est de l'aspect puis dire c'est
quoi la spectacle c'était nouveau pour
moi et puis il ya beaucoup de fruits et
légumes que je découvre ici certains que
j'ai déjà dit et d'autres un peu moins
je sais pas trop comment m'y prendre
parfois oui on le rappeler mais vous
laisser ça à l'intérieur le poulet yassa
cuit dans les épices le citron et les
oignons et mélanger à la courge
spaghetti qui sert même de plat de
présentation chacun à doser les
ingrédients à son goût on déguste une
bouchée de chacune des recettes
c'est vraiment bon et bien fondant là
mais c'est vraiment mon bon les amis 20
sur 20 vous êtes prêts pour top chef le
grand beau et si vous nous verrez
c'était pour moi la nouvelle
les gonds que je peux utiliser un volet
nutrition est intégré à l'atelier sophie
la nutritionniste explique aujourd'hui
comment défricher les étiquettes
nutritionnelles pour aider à faire de
meilleurs choix pour nous à l'édifice
l'allemagne de qualité ou les maladies
métaboliques une prévalence très
importante au pays pourra prendre en
charge très tôt ces immigrants la leur
permettent d'avoir comme une bonne
alimentation une saines habitudes de vie
pas vraiment ralentir le développement
ces maladies il affecté ici c'est
important de mettre en place des
interventions qui vont faciliter leur
activation à l'espace alimentaire locale
brice ya tente d'intégrer les notions
apprises dans ses ateliers
elle prépare à la maison un mets
typiquement mexicain avec un légume
qu'elle vient de découvrir le rutabaga
mais sous les conseils de sa mère au
mexique elle fêtera goût avec une salsa
béria à base de piments sec rôti cuit
broyer avec oignons et tomates la sauce
est mélangée aux 8 à bagua dans un
ragoût de viande ou en version
végétarienne les mélanges les savoirs
sont sommes vraiment mais manque on
arrive dans une nouvelle société une
nouvelle culture faut ça pour crier
aussi de cette culture là pour être
vraiment épanouie et que le fait
d'utiliser aliments locaux et de les
revisiter un peu avec nous notre
identité mais c'est une forme
d'intégration aussi l'intégration par
l'alimentation par un autre jour pour
moi c'est l'une des meilleures et que
pourquoi ne pas faire ça et donc c'est
ce choc culturel
il faut il faut il faut bénéficier et
donc du coup à cette petite échelle a
commencé comme ça puis en espérant que
ça est vraiment d'impact dans la société
l'on vit ensemble on vit ensemble vivons
ensemble
[Musique]